this is of course very unlikely because
I can't program but I'd like to create
it I walk up where for every day of the
year the user can just click on the app
and it'll show like your block piece of
the day so maybe that's an independent
piece or maybe it's a movement of a
sweet but every day there's a new piece
because there's so many pieces not just
keyboard works but there's corals
there's violin pieces cello pieces
orchestra suites and every day i'm going
to attempt to put a new one and i think
there's enough for like three years if
every day is different and with each
piece i'd like to provide a short
summary of what the piece is about of
what kind of a dance it is of course
that's a lot of research so that's going
to take a while to get together but
that's what i like to do in the future
and just get people to find out what the
doc pieces of the day is and then if I
can't fit the whole piece of music on
the app then maybe provide a link for
them to go to youtube and listen to it
and see what kind of music that they're
actually interested in and I'm sure
they'll find something within this
massive amount of works so in essence
it's going to help people explore more
of Bach's music
classical music now has become less
successful than it was maybe fifty
hundred years ago now when we have pop
albums coming out there ten dollars an
album that every store at every store
you can imagine Walmart Target wherever
you want and everybody can just get
access to them easily and also the music
itself is very accessible it's not as
complex as what Bach and other classical
musicians wrote certainly there's a lot
of instruments but when you look at say
symphonies or the corrals or masses
there's much more instruments there's
maybe a hundred singers and an orchestra
so I think people haven't discovered
their own interest for digging deeper
into these kinds of musics these kinds
of music they are just kind of
interested in having something nice to
hear